on the 16th of September 2022 news broke
that Maser amini a 22 year old Kurdish
woman died in custody following her
arrest by the gershad Iran's morality
police for improperly wearing her hijab
the news of her death spark protests in
Tehran which quickly spread to towns and
cities across Iran becoming the
country's longest major protests against
the ruling Islamic Republic
while Iran is no stranger to protests
the current demonstrations are unique
not only because they are about the
rights of women but that they're being
led by them too
so why are the Iranian protests being
driven by women
[Music]
when viewing the continuing process in
Iran it's important to consider the
wider historical and geographical
context that they are a part of
Iran is home to one of the oldest
civilizations in the world one that has
a rich history of traditions and
religions
where women were not only highly
respected but in some cases considered
equals of men
it's hard not to see that historical and
geographical influence in some of the
powerfully symbolic ways women are
protesting now
the hair cutting gesture adopted by
protesters activists celebrities and
politicians has its origins in Persian
literature
the epic poem that tells the story of
the Persian Empire from the creation of
the world until the Muslim Conquest
refers to foreign geese cutting her hair
and binding it to her waist to protest
and mourn her husband's death
the Kurdish slogan adopted by protesters
Jin Jen Azadi
meaning woman life Freedom also has
particular Regional significance
Masa amini was one of an estimated 10
million Kurds living in Iran
massa's Kurdish name is Gina but Kurdish
names are deemed unacceptable in Iran on
the grounds that they are considered
foreign and unislamic
the slogan has spread globally and can
be heard at protests around the world in
a show of solidarity for the movement in
Iran
the early 20th century was a tumultuous
time in Iranian history
but the years following World War II saw
a period of relative stability that
ushered in many social and economic
reforms
among them were many gains for the
rights of women
the right to vote came in 1963.
and the Family Protection Law granted
women equal rights in marriage and
divorce
enhanced women's rights in child custody
and increased the minimum age of
marriage
there was also a greater access to
education in 1966 just over 17 percent
of the Iranian female population were
literate
this Rose to 35.5 percent by 1976.
women also entered public office for the
first time
but in 1979 the Islamic revolution
marked a significant change in direction
for Iran and many of the rights of women
were rolled back
on March the 8th 1979 a month after
Ayatollah khomeini's rise to power a
march to celebrate International women's
day transformed into a massive protest
against new enforced modesty rules for
women but despite the demonstrations
lasting for six days by 1983 Waring of
the hijab was made compulsory
[Music]
even today as Iranian authorities
continue to restrict the rights of
Iranian women
it's hard not to see the legacy of the
gains that were made during the mid-20th
century
Iranian women are now more educated than
ever and are demanding greater
opportunities to shape their lives
literacy rates among young women between
15 to 24 have soared to 99 in 2021 and
as of 2019 women made up 58 of a
university enrollments
as a result this generation of young
Highly Educated women and girls are
protesting rules that limit their
freedom of movement right to bodily
autonomy and access to enter the labor
force
and despite the Iranian government's
Crackdown
that has seen many women and girls being
killed beaten and incarcerated
the protest movement continues